(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos estudar sobre dação em pagamento.
A gente já falou lá no módulo 2, mas vamos deixar aqui registrado também para
que você possa recorrer a essa aula sempre que achar necessário.
O que é dação em pagamento?
Dação em pagamento é um acordo convencionado entre credor e devedor, no qual o
credor aceita receber prestação diversa do que lhe é devida.
Uma observação, o credor não é obrigado a receber prestação diversa ainda que
seja de maior valor.
Então, vamos a um exemplo hipotético.
Eu emprestei 20 mil reais a você e você deveria me pagar em dinheiro.
Você não tem o dinheiro para me pagar e você me faz uma proposta.
Você tem um carro que vale 25 mil reais e você me oferece esse carro como
pagamento.
Perceba, o seu carro vale mais do que efetivamente você me deve.
Afinal, o seu carro vale 25 mil e você me deve 20 mil.
Nem assim eu sou obrigada a aceitar o seu carro como pagamento.
Eu posso ou não aceitar, porque o que ficou convencionado entre a gente no
momento que eu te emprestei o dinheiro era que eu deveria receber o pagamento
também em dinheiro.
Eu posso ou não aceitar.
Quando a dação em pagamento é realizada tendo como objeto um imóvel, ocorre a
transferência da propriedade do imóvel do devedor para o credor.
Então, vamos a um outro exemplo.
Eu emprestei 200 mil reais para alguém e essa pessoa deveria me pagar em
dinheiro.
Foi isso que ficou estipulado no momento que eu emprestei o dinheiro.
Chega no prazo que ela tinha para me pagar e ela não tem o dinheiro.
Ela me faz uma proposta.
Olha, eu tenho um apartamento de 250 mil reais.
Eu não tenho os 200 para te pagar, mas eu topo transferir esse meu apartamento
para você.
Você aceita ou não?
Eu poderia muito bem recusar.
Afinal de contas, mesmo por ser mais valioso, eu não seria obrigada a aceitar.
Mas eu aceitei.
Então eu falei, tudo bem, eu aceito o seu pagamento.
Vamos transferir a propriedade desse apartamento para mim.
A partir do momento que é realizada uma dação em pagamento tendo como objeto um
imóvel, o credor vai ser o novo proprietário daquele apartamento.
Porque o apartamento passou do devedor para o credor como forma de pagamento de
uma dívida.
Então, como o credor é o novo proprietário, nada impede que aquele apartamento
que no nosso exemplo aqui, ele passou a ser o proprietário, que ele tenha
aquele apartamento penhorado para pagar dívidas que ele possui.
Então vamos supor, eu aceitei esse apartamento de 250 mil, sou a nova
proprietária daquele apartamento, mas eu estou respondendo na justiça por um
processo que alguém está me cobrando alguma dívida.
E a justiça me condena e eu não tenho nenhum outro bem.
Eu só tenho aquele apartamento que eu recebi em dação em pagamento.
Nada impede que esse meu apartamento, ele seja penhorado para pagar dívidas
minhas.
Afinal de contas, eu sou a nova proprietária daquele apartamento.
E tudo bem, o leilão vai acontecer normalmente.
Você só precisa saber que quando existe uma dação em pagamento, vai ocorrer
essa transferência de propriedade de um devedor para um credor.
E se o bem for leiloado por uma dívida do credor, tudo bem, o leilão acontece
normalmente.
É só para você saber mesmo o que significa esse termo dação em pagamento que
existem em muitas matrículas de imóveis que a gente encontra em leilão.